if you
Nicki Rod definitively beat Gordon Ryan
how would you do it buggy truck Bucky
choke foggy choke uh for the listener
I don't even know how to describe buggy
jokes uh what's what's the definitive
like conclusion on on that joke does it
work it's a it's a joke that you do when
you're in a uh what's the opposite of a
dominant it's not submissive in a
non-dominant position of bottom of side
control yeah just embarrassing
submission to get caught with really
yeah but does it work it works on
certain people
for the listener he glassed over at
Nicky it's embarrassing but it's also
what it's a way to frustrate the the
opponent for sure yeah it's a new part
of the sport I feel like the rotolos
brought it back into fashion and even if
you don't get it because it's one of
those moves that's so embarrassing at
the first sign of danger the top guy
abandoned ship and you can basically
retain God by attempting a very
embarrassing Center so the threat of
embarrassment yes everybody people pull
out very quick to avoid
suffering the consequences I think some
people underestimate how uh good of a
submission it is I mean like once you're
locked in there there's not too many
defenses for a buggy joke
I it are you is there an instructional
on the way from you on the j-rod
actually a little brother has one oh
yeah for real you actually legit have
oh wow
that's awesome we'll check it out so I
mean there is I mean you're making a
joke out of it but it is a real like
there's a system to it I mean yeah I
don't know if we call it assistant
it's a good move
I mean you take an opponent uh that was
just winning in a in a in a greatly
dominant position and then boom in that
same position they're pretty much
they're losing you know it's uh it's an
interesting move what's the name of the
uh what's the name of it it's called The
Buggy pedia like Jay Rodriguez okay the
the bugipedia I thought there'd be
something like very Craig Jonesy about
it okay awesome uh I know you don't want
to sort of reveal the secrets of what
you're working on but in general dude
what does it take to beat Gordon I guess
okay it would have to be some kind of a
choke I think any joint lock or anything
like that he's just gonna let it break
and stay in the match so I don't even
think he'd tap from like a uh Arena
choke I think I would have to put him to
sleep so um putting him asleep a solid
one so Gordon is somebody who really
he's losing yeah like he won't even tap
in the in the practice room I remember
like I had a total hold a couple times
in practice room and he was just
comfortable like working there I'm like
I'm not really putting much on it I
think he just you know maybe because of
situations like that in practice he kind
of didn't respect my to hold's ability
in in the competition you've done that
to me in the practice yes I have yeah
yeah I'll give you a little give me a
little pup and then he let go okay
[Laughter]
um is there some part of that you think
is necessary to be a champion is to like
this almost unwillingness and
competition attempt I think there's
definitely something to be said for
people that are just like uh you know
willing to go that extra mile or to take
that damage to secure their their
victory
um is there part of you that like would
hate to tap or hate the tap yeah I mean
all of me
yeah oh the whole part of me uh isn't
there a John Legend song like that all
of you and all of me very romantic yeah
yeah we're sticking on that theme okay
I'm sorry uh oh one of the things uh
Gordon uh asked I forget how you put it
because I think there's a lot of words
that would need to be censored involved
but he said ask them
um how it feels to have a zero five
record against me with four submissions
combined I mean first of all I wasn't
sure he could count to five yeah that's
an impressive
um oh and five I mean I always say one
thing nobody beats me four times
I love you so much I did have a question
I did have a question for you
there was some controversy on your
Twitter
yeah about a list of books yeah and I
was wondering
why Gordon's book wasn't featured
amongst that literature well it was only
the first 30 books or like the first 20
books it would of course be in uh
something interesting about Gordon he's
the first author that's written more
books than he's read
pretty good uh
if you if you face someone beat them
like what's your take on what it takes
to be Gordon I you guys are kind of joke
and you go pretty pretty hard recently
uh on each other but as a fan of jiu
jitsu I'm all in on this rivalry it's
just fun to watch I mean first of all I
don't think I go really hard with him I
think Gordon is he's pretty sensitive
you know I mean he's looking
for a large insult in a small insult and
for me like Australians we just attack
each other all day every day and for me
like if I see someone that takes himself
very seriously that's like blood in the
water that's funny to me to me if I can
just gently provoke and get a strong
reaction that's hilarious like Aussies
we will just attack each other and the
first person that gets upset he kind of
loses the exchange
so I think that is very very
entertaining like if you were to beat
Gordon would the mental game off the map
be part of it
I think it would be a fact of a shoba I
mean I'm never gonna come out too crazy
direct with him you know like I don't I
cough I find that like if you get too
upset on the line and you're going crazy
I'll find that I'd be embarrassed to do
that myself obviously each everyone's
different everyone has a different style
you know but like yeah I think mental
the mental aspect would play a big
factor I mean
mainly because if I were to beat him
I would send him a message every day
until I died yeah just to gently remind
him but I got the last one the last one
it's all that matters
so like once you beat them you're going
to run for the rest of your life
I mean run but look back yeah with
messages
right ride your horse into the sunset
okay